a lot of League fans are sick of cutesy
or attractive or anime looking champions
in League of Legends last week when Riot
announced the game's latest champion
smolder there was such a backlash
against his design that Riot actually
did a last minute uturn for a lot of
people this is all just confirmation of
a shift in R's design policy from which
we may never
[Music]
return
so last week League fans got a teaser
for the upcoming Dragon Champion smolder
aka the fiery fledgling the reaction
from the community was mixed to put it
lightly some were immediately drawn to
the cuteness of the design and you can
see why he's a young dragon that got
separated from his mom and was lost at
sea it is begging for your sympathy but
for a lot of others it was just a bit
creepy sm's face seemed to enter into
The Uncanny V Al not quite Dragon not
quite human but something that sat
uncomfortably between the two people
even had to go at fixing smoulder While
others were reminded of the Sonic the
Hedgehog disaster which saw Paramount
redesign the video game Icon after fans
overwhelmingly dubb the liveaction
adaptation to be creepy and upsetting
now it's not the first time there have
been complaints about a new Champion
design so most people expected Riot to
just let the whole thing fizzle out but
to many people's surprised they actually
followed the examp Le set by Paramount
and Sonic and tried to fix it Riot
product manager lexical announced that
they'd heard the community feedback on
sm's face and would be adjusting his
features smolder was given more
prominent scales and dragon-like
features and people weren't just pleased
with the results they were pleasantly
surprised with the fact that Riot
actually u-turned at all on this because
the reality is Riot doesn't tend to do
that by and large they seem very happy
with their design philosophy and if
you've been paying attention in recent
years you might have noticed a trend
because the fact is a lot of Champions
these days are for one to a better word
a bit cutesy for every old grotesque
Champion like Fiddlesticks chogath or
Mundo there are modern Champions like
zeri or seraphine that look like they've
stepped right out of an anime some say
the star Guardian skin line is
influenced by Sailor Moon battle
Academia looks a lot like my hero
Academia and Super Galaxy seems to draw
on shows like gurin Len but this
particular debate seems to be less about
anime having no place in League at all
and more about it taking up the Lion
Share of inspiration at the cost of
thematic diversity now this is a very
sensitive topic that people feel very
strongly about and debate very fiercely
online and it's really up to you to
decide where you land on it all a recent
post on the subreddit epitomized the
Feeling by some saying enough with this
anime thing I want ugly monster and even
if that was a little bit tongue-in-cheek
is it just as simple as that does
creating monsters equal good Champion
design well as one commenter pointed out
it's more that people are looking for
creative designs along the likes of
thresh rexi or fiddles sticks rather
than just repulsive creatures and to go
one step further even humanoid designs
aren't inherently bad look at gragas
singed alloi all uniquely designed
humanoids that don't fit the mold we've
been talking about but at the end of the
day for all the frustrations people have
about Champions being too cute or too
humanoid or too attract or too anime
there's a reason Riot does this back in
March 2021 a lot of people felt like
they' been baited by Riot during Gwen's
release when her champion model seemed
to be very different to how she looked
in her teaser trailer they were
expecting a creepy animated dull but
thought the final product was nothing
more than just yet another cookie cutter
human on Reddit RI a reev said of Riot's
design philosophy quote we are defining
it now as human humanoid and creature
and going to be more more deliberate to
make sure we are making Champs in all
three that we will still likely be doing
mainly human slh humanoid Champions with
creatures thrown in since creatures tend
to be much lower play rate in general we
still want to make them it's just a
smaller audience so we will generally
make less a smaller audience for
creature Champions means they're going
to sell less skins which is obviously a
huge consideration in Champion Design
This is a business after all if you look
at which Champions have the most skins
it's no surprise that Champions like
aalii Lux and Misfortune top the list
with 19 each they have the exact design
mold we've been talking about so is this
all really a big issue well would more
diversity in Champion design be a good
thing in League of Legends yes I think
we can all agree on that but RI
obviously have to think about business
too here people didn't like the look of
smolder last week there was a lot of
backlash about this human face on a tiny
dragon Riot listened and they fixed it
some people are still saying that smer
should look even more like a dragon and
less like a human there has to be some
level of compromise here players are
simply more drawn to humanoids or
heavily personified creatures so when
Riot decided to release a new Dragon
Champion it's not really too much of a
surprise they went down this design
route if you don't like the sound of
that and I'm sure there are some of you
who don't let me ask you this question
do you think Shiana the original Dragon
champion in League would sell as many
skins if she was released today in 2024
for then again you could say is money
everything that should be taken into
account here it's a debate that's going
to keep coming up every time Riot
releases a champion that's too human or
too cutesy or too attractive or too
cookie cutter or too anime so just let
me know what you think now how do I I've
wrote down pronunciation for this very
very good thinking by me gurin lagen
gurin Len sounds like a sounds like a
Danish beer I was going to say it sounds
like a beer I have two g l
please yeah yeah no logo in the
phone
um I fancy a pint now